morning welcome to Executive session the
criminal justice Public Safety before we
begin would you please join me in Rising
to say our national anthem no I mean I
Pledge of Allegiance I'm not saying
for all
right
this time I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill
no that's not that's her
and I would recognize representative gas
right for a motion
what about it
oh she got it I think all right
we only have 351 for the Amendments we
didn't get the rest of it okay with
everyone relax
upstairs
we are um waiting for a quick amendment
that I'll be here in about a minute
um so we're going to stand in recess
until that arrives
Hi man
okay yeah
so this is the one
foreign
does everyone have one on this side no
no oh we have a 351 over here
all right maybe eight yeah
all right
I have extras of 588 okay anybody needs
some
laughs
okay everybody got it yes
foreign
I'm reopening the executive session on
house drill
588 and I recognize representative
Harriet gathwright to make a motion
High motion
to
accept the amendment for 588 amendment
number 2023-0583h
do I hear a second
representative salic seconds
uh would you like to speak to your
motion yes
um the the amendment has three changes
on it
um
I can we we change the complete the
percentage from 50 to 65 percent
that a person minimum sentence
could be possibly go before the parole
board
we also changed the
sentenced to a minimum of not less than
seven and a half years
and we also made sure that it was not
um
you could retroactive
so it will start from the effective date
thank you
um
would you like to speak to your second
representative
I just think it's great that we are
I fully Concur and agree with that and I
hope that the members would look at this
favorably we looked at it we talked
about it together we worked on it we
took care of some of the concerns we had
and I I think that it's important to
give incarcerated people
um at least a chance at the hope that if
they work hard and follow the rules that
they can
have a chance at an earlier release and
it's only a chance because I still have
to go by the parole board
so I think this is a good thing and I
would encourage the members to support
it further discussion
seeing none I would ask the clerk to
call the roll
motion is adoption of amendment zero
five eight three h Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt
yes
representative Hill yes representative
Prue yes representative janvin yes
representative Banyan yes representative
Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes representative Catherine yeah
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the cleric votes yes representative
Newell yes representative selig yes
representative wheeler okay
chairman Roy
cheer votes yes I don't uh amendment is
adopted 22.
thank you
um at this point I would recommend uh
excuse me I would recognize Harry uh
representative here at gathright for an
emotion
lawyer second
representative wheeler seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
yes
um I truly believe that this is a good a
very good bill
and it changes some of the Antiquated
you know um
I guess verbiage in our books that we
have here and um in the laws so
one thing about this that was a little
bit different from some of the others is
that this one is strictly on Behavior
you have to change your behavior to even
get this where others that are on the
books today is not based on a change in
the person's Behavior it's based on you
know
let me do this just so I can get out you
can't do that with this particular one
so I'm happy that the team decided to um
voted in
thank you representative wheeler would
you like to speak to your second
uh I just want to acknowledge the
powerful testimony that we heard during
public hearing of people who went to
prison as teenagers uh displayed good
behavior and wanted that hope of getting
out based on that good behavior and I
appreciate this legislation brought
forward by representative gathright to
give us a chance to have those people
who display good behavior and are
rehabilitated give them a chance to
actually go out in the world as
rehabilitated people
thank you
um I would add that I believe that this
has been attempted for years we've been
trying to do this and I'm I'm very
pleased that we're finally able to come
together and get a piece of legislation
out that actually
um achieves everything that every
everyone's happy with so uh
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman I I would just like to add on
something that I would I would like for
everybody just to kind of like focus on
and follow up to everything that's
already been said is just how hard we
really worked on this and all the
stakeholders actually listened to every
single thing that people didn't like and
addressed that and if you have you know
committed a violent crime against
um a child this is not going to count
for you that you're no
um in addition to that you know if you
get yourself in trouble once you know
you're you're already incarcerated
doesn't doesn't apply there
um in and and the biggest thing is
um any kind of crime like a sexual
nature doesn't apply and for that I
think is
why we're actually all able to
sounds like come together so um just
wanted to acknowledge that
thank you any further discussion radio
I'm representative Murphy thank you Mr
chair
um I will be supporting this bill though
I do wish I recognize the value and and
that's why I will be voting in support
the only thing that I wish that it had
and I think I'm hoping that we can look
at down the road is
um you know as a strong child advocate
um I think this has got great value but
I also worry about other vulnerable
populations like this disabled or the
elderly and then we have a carve out for
children which is a great thing but a
violent crime if you're the victim it
doesn't matter if you're 17 or 19 or 85
that's the only thing that is a little
rough on me but I will I will support
the bill because I recognize the the
value
thank you and I acknowledge it as well
no bill is perfect and there's always
rooms to work on it and I hope that we
can look at those issues in the coming
year and see if we can fix that as well
um any further discussion
seeing none that will ask the clerk to
call the roll this is ought to pass as
amended
Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt yes
representative Hill yes representative
Prue yes representative janvin yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Catherine
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
salic yes
representative wheeler yeah
yeah chairman Roy gerbils yes motion
passes 2-0
I'll spill
588 passes as amended unanimously in the
objection to consent
seeing none and it will go on consent
and
um again I'd like to thank
representative here Cathay for bringing
this forward and I wish her and the bill
luck going forward as it travels through
its process with that I close the
executive session houseboat 588. the
next bill we have on the calendar is
House Bill 653 will be not taking that
up today there's issues that need to be
worked on with the sponsor and other
people so we're not taking it up House
Bill 624 relative to immigration
checkpoints I hereby open the executive
session and I recognize representative
stone for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion to re excuse me to uh itl 624
well here's a second
second by representative tanza uh
representative would you like to speak
to your motion Mr chair I would
uh we should not be uh placing
responsibility of notification
requirements on state or local law
enforcement agencies in regards to this
bill uh the sole purpose of the BPA are
responsible for the border security of
the United States and that would also
lead to impeding their efforts
at the end of the day
thank you representative tensor I would
like to speak to you a second
I concur with representative Stone
thank you I also Concur and I I believe
that at a time right now especially a
northern border they're seeing um
unlawful Crossings up over 300 percent
and it's
um we don't need to interfere in the
process of the federal government is
trying to take care of that this
whatever way they choose it's not within
our
our bail a week to deal with and our law
enforcement has enough to do without
worrying about this issue and further
discussion representative Newell
yeah I just I just wanted to comment um
especially given what's been said so far
as it you know it it's very very
straightforward and very simple
um it really doesn't take a lot to to
just put up a notification there are a
variety of different ways that you could
do that the bill provides for a variety
of different uh ways to be able to just
notify people
um so that it is not an inconvenience to
our tourists and travelers and residents
and things like that I I just think um
uh I just I just want to
um amplify the the Simplicity of it you
know just things very basic
thank you and and I appreciate and um
understand your motives for it and um it
is doable
um having said that I just don't want to
do it I don't think that it's at this
point something that is unnecessary but
I do understand it further discussion
oh yeah representative
um Muse
so one of the one of the issues is that
these stops can take place
um up to 100 miles away from the border
and there have been uh some some of
these uh checkpoints have actually been
set up uh not really even close uh to
the Border uh in the past we have no
guarantees that those won't be set up
again
when these happen they present an
enormous amount of difficulty especially
the ones that are set up in the notch
during tourist season for local
residents and I think one of the things
that they do is they create an
environment of fear for people who are
new to this country or who don't
necessarily look like the majority of
the members of this committee
um this is a very simple thing it
doesn't get in the way of the
enforcement activity all it does is
provide notice advance notice to people
that this is something that's going to
be taking place it's something we
already require for sobriety checkpoints
in this state so
I'm not sure I understand the issue
I'll be voting against it eitl thank you
further discussion yes where you
representative here Gathering
yes I'm going to be voting against the
itls as well we had we heard quite a bit
of testimony that you know that people
are stopped and they're really not being
stopped
um you know for the causes that they
give because they send Dogs Out bring
dogs out and now they check in the car
and really interrupting the person's day
and from my understanding the same way
that our officers our law enforcement is
notified that the stops are going to
occur so it's not like there's anything
special anything new that our
um
state troopers would have to do but
notify folks so that folks can at least
know I'm going to get stopped today I
might be late to work and whatever the
course of the day may be so I think it's
really a good film it's a good um
gesture just for anyone that's near the
borderline and I had to agree with um
representative
um use that
the fact that it's so far away from the
Line crossing the border I think that
distance is ridiculous so I would be
voting against the itl
thank you
um I I appreciate that as well that is a
long distance 100 miles having said that
the appropriate place for that to be
addressed would be to our federal
delegation I'm concerned that this would
pit our local law enforcement against
federal law enforcement and what would
happen is the federal law enforcement
would just cease to notify the local law
enforcement because it interferes in
their mission
and I don't think we need to put our law
enforcement in between us and the
federal government
it just pits them in the middle of it
like two parents fighting and I just
don't think it's a good idea to put them
in that position representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I'd just like to
point out that Federal immigration is
exactly that handled by the federal
government is not a state entity it is
not a state enforcement it is strictly
Federal which means we cannot really
interfere with them conducting their
checkpoints
representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman I want to agree
with what representative Muse and
representative gathwright said but I
would also add on to president
representative gather I'd said it's not
just a impediment on your day it's an
impediment on your Fourth Amendment
right uh to
and I I really do think that that's
um the biggest uh concern for me here is
that we have a it seems to me a hundred
mile zone between uh the border and the
coast which encompasses our entire state
where the Fourth Amendment does not
apply if the federal government chooses
to run one of these checkpoints and we
heard testimony from uh people like Mr
Fuentes in the audience there who told
us about what it was like to to go
through one of these checkpoints and I'm
not I'm sure all of us understand that
that's definitely something that was of
a tad bit of concern to us I think the
federal government would notify us I
disagree with your concern but hear that
I think they would ultimately notify the
state if they were to run a checkpoint
on our interstates or our roads
um as they have in the past and I think
this legislation is is as representative
Newell said simple enough to to pass it
we it's not restricting the federal
government use of these checkpoints or
saying that you can't do them anymore
it's just saying the public should be
notified just as we are in a sobriety
checkpoint and considering these are
impeding traffic and impeding people's
rights I think are the state government
just as we did for guns saying we're
going to stand up against the federal
government and make sure that your
fourth amendment is protected is the
right thing to do so I'll be voting
against the ideal motion thank you I
appreciate your consistency in reminding
us of the recent debate I was having
Deja Vu I didn't know where I heard this
argument before
um representative who's next to you oh
go ahead okay
thank you Mr chair
um much of what representative wheeler
said is
um my concern as well I feel like in
this committee we've been good at
understanding you know the roles of the
state and federal law enforcement and
how they apply differently to things in
our state and I don't see how asking our
state law enforcement to notify the
public that their constitutional rights
will be superseded in the event they
come across one of these checkpoints is
asking them to interfere in federal law
enforcement's efforts especially since
to my understanding these checkpoints
don't often even result in a slow of
illegal immigration or anything they're
just used as a way to
incarcerate and charge New Hampshire
citizens with completely different
crimes that are found out through their
constitutional rights being violated
when they're pulled over without cause
and their vehicles are searched and
their identities are questioned it's
just setting up
um you know the it's setting up people
to have their rides violated without due
cause and without even I think good
reason because of the lack of efficacy
of these efforts in the first place by
federal law enforcement to slow illegal
immigration
um so I I would definitely be voting
against the itl motion I think that as
we've had discussions in this committee
before when citizens are being asked to
give up certain rights they should know
that they're going to be asked to do so
it should be under a specific set of
circumstances and allowing federal law
enforcement to come into our state and
harass New Hampshire citizens just
whenever they please does not
um make sense to me thank you
thank you representative salic
thank you just to add a personal
experience to the discussion
with the usaid and therefore I was born
out of the country my first passport
photos were taken when I was 10 years
old
um but when I have been stopped which I
have at checkpoints in this country and
they find out that I was born in
Pakistan the first question they asked
was me for proof that I'm a U.S citizen
I don't normally travel with my passport
if I have noticed that there's going to
be a potential checkpoints in the areas
where I'm traveling around the state
then I know that I need that day to make
sure I have my passport with me because
they don't view my driver's license
which is a verified driver's license
with all the extra checks on it as
sufficient enough and the number of
questions I have to go through
as a child of two U.S citizens as a U.S
citizen and as someone who was born out
of the country because my father was
representing the US government still
leads me to have challenges
thank you may I inquire how do they know
that you weren't born in the United
States based on your driver's license
they don't know it based on my driver's
license they ask questions such as where
were you born and when I say I was born
in ralphindy Pakistan
they say you know can you prove your
citizenship and I'm like well if you
want to go to my house and grab my
passport sure and they're like well you
know we're blah blah blah from your
it's an issue thank you that's a very uh
very interesting point
um further discussion representative
Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I also think we heard in testimony
that often these stops happen on like
super busy holiday weekends Labor Day
weekend Bike Week Etc and not only does
that make highway traffic more dangerous
for the public but it also has um it's
severely hampering the experiences of
New Hampshire families when they're
trying to enjoy these weekends you know
I can say as someone who lives in
Southern New Hampshire going up to
Laconia is not something that happens
every week and if I'm gonna make an hour
drive I want to know that I'm going to
get to where I want to go with my family
in an hour and I'm not going to be at a
checkpoint on a holiday weekend for six
hours because all these cars are getting
stopped randomly
thank you representative wheeler just a
point of information for the committee
in the 2022 session HB 579 passed
through the house on a roll call vote
254 to 85 and that was a similar piece
of legislation to this right here
thank you
any further no okay and I'll ask the
court to go
the motion is itl currently
Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative Prue yes representative
janvin yes
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed
yes representative Stone yes
representative tenser yes representative
Catherine yeah no sorry
representative Muse
representative Oldham no representative
Bradley no representative Murphy no
representative Newman
no the clerk votes now representative
Newell no Representative salic no
representative wheeler
no
chairman Roy
votes yes
motion is 10 10. 10 10 motion fails the
mo uh the bill is open for further
motions
Mr chair I I move uh Amendment
um
uh Amendment uh
20230416h to HB 624 FN thank you do I
hear a second
representative um
Newell seconds
and would you like to speak to your
motion representative
what this amendment does is it brings
the uh the current bill uh 100 in line
with the bill that overwhelmingly passed
in the house last year
what the amendment actually does is
provide some additional species
more specifics it provides more
specifics uh around the notification
requirement itself and how it's uh how
it's supposed to be done this amendment
uh I believe came to us from the ACLU
last year and they they were they
actually uh were were helpful in kind of
getting us over the home with this one
so what this does effectively is is put
the uh the same bill that passed
overwhelmingly in the house last year uh
back on the table
thank you would you like to speak to
your second
further discussion
seeing none um this is uh going to be a
vote on adopting the amendment I would
ask to call the roll
Vice chair Rhodes
yes
representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative Prue yes representative
janvin
no
representative Manion
representative Reed yes
representative Stone
no
representative tenzar
yes
representative goth right
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salic yes representative
wheeler chairman Roy gerbilts yes motion
is adopted 18-2
uh recognize
um representative Muse for a motion
Mr chair I move HB 624 FN as amended
ought to pass now second
motion seconded by representative Harry
gathright representative music you'd
like to speak to your motion
I think we've had a a very robust
discussion of this so far and I'm not
sure I can actually add anything to it
there are many good reasons uh to pass
this bill
um I know that all of us are concerned
uh about the Integrity of the Border uh
but realistically I'm I'm not sure uh
how much this particular enforcement
effort actually helps us uh and one of
the things unfortunately that it does
accomplish is it it violates the rights
of some of our citizens
and it uh
it's it's something that uh and I think
what we're not doing is we're not
nullifying federal law we're not
overturning New Hampshire law all we're
basically saying is is if you're going
to do this notify us and given the fact
that stopping traffic on a major
interstate highway like I-93 uh can
present safety issues and traffic issues
this seems to be a pretty pretty
reasonable thing to do and it's
something we already do for sobriety
checkpoints so I would urge folks to to
maybe take another look at it and uh uh
and vote your conscience thank you thank
you for your great specificity
um representative Newell did you want to
speak in a sec who's seconded it
representative Harry gathway would you
like the second uh I just want to make a
comment because I I think I heard
someone say that um
um we do not want
our officers to work with the federal
government et cetera et cetera however
the animals that are being brought out
there are brought out by our law
enforcement not by the federal
government
you're talking about working dogs right
oh okay thank you
um I was confused about things I'm
talking about the dogs that usually they
come to smell for drugs
oh okay thank you
um further discussion
um represent Stone
thank you Mr chair I just like to point
out that uh part of border patrol is
responsible for drug enforcement so that
does fall into their purview uh the
other thing I want to point out is uh
these checkpoints
if you give proper notice and people
avoid them it defeats the purpose of
doing them if you have the thought
process of well maybe we should notice
everybody well maybe we should do that
for every crime so that they know where
we're doing everything and in regards to
the Superior Court issuing orders for
sobriety checkpoints that's actually one
element of a huge packet that has to be
authorized by a Superior Court Justice
it includes notifications just one
element of that there's a lot more that
falls into it
thank you representative representative
janburn
thank you Mr chairman
I just want to point out uh in reading
the amendment now this is otpa so I'm
going to talk about the amendment it
states clearly that when an estate
County or Municipal Police Department or
law enforcement agencies informed they
shall
uh and and then I go to the New
Hampshire Constitution Article 28a the
state shall not mandate or assign any
new expanded or modified programs or
responsibilities to any political
subdivision in any way to necessitate
additional local expenditures by the
political subdivision unless such
programs or responsibilities are fully
funded by the state or unless such
programs or responsibilities are
approved by the funding by a vote of the
local legislative body or the political
subdivision I am definitely a no on this
vote
I appreciate that concern uh however I
do believe the amendment says they can
use their website which would be no
additional cost
um representative new Newman
I just want to remind the committee that
we as we've said in previous sessions we
vote on policy if this in fact is a
violation of 28a it goes to finance they
make the determination that it isn't a
violation
and then
the that takes care of that
thank you
um further discussion representative
Murray oh
representative Newell
yeah I mean throughout this conversation
it's just kind of um reminded me of you
know the story that I was talking about
with uh testing and analyzing equipment
and and why you know that being
considered uh what was in my car was
considered drug paraphernalia allowed
them to negate my civil liberties and uh
that kind of thing and I feel like
essentially what this does at the end of
the day is sets up a situation like that
but it is casting a very wide net
um in order to really not accomplish its
goal uh at the end of the day what it
does is it uh you know at the end of the
day what it what the
outcome is is catching a lot of people
doing you know other things that uh
wouldn't warrant this type of behavior
um and not its intended goal thank you
representative salig
thank you just to Echo what
representative Newell Singh in 2022 one
of the checkpoints said zero zero
immigration
um detentions but between 13 and 16
marijuana
um detentions
if the goal of these checkpoints is to
catch illegal immigrants or people
crossing the border without permission
then that should be the focus not
searching for marijuana
Murray
okay Mr chair I just wanted to make a
quick comment that you know we do notify
about sobriety checkpoints and as far as
I know they are still very effective I
think like potentially you know it could
be argued that um to make immigration
checkpoints less effective but I think
that needs to be weighed against at one
point do we allow our civil liberties
and constitutional rights to be
superseded by the government and I think
this is one of these cases where we need
to put New Hampshire citizens and their
rights first as per usual the ad in this
committee
thank you
um
I found Representatives selig's points
very compelling I too have a son with a
consular report of birth who was born in
Germany
um so that it does seem to be rather
burdensome for New Hampshire citizens so
I would encourage members to all vote
their conscience on this bill and with
that I would ask the court to call the
roll
motion is ought to pass with Amendment
Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt no
representative Hill yes
representative Prue
no
Representative janvin no representative
Manion no
representative Reed no
representative Stone no
representative tanzai yes
representative Harriet gothright
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes
representative salik yes representative
wheelie yay chairman Roy
gerbilt yes motion passes fourteen six
house bill which one is
624 passes
um
and that will be on a regular calendar
um representative Stone would you like
to write The Minority Report
thank you Mr chair and who will be
writing a report for the majority of
Representative Muse
I will write the I will write it if you
need somebody right now we we did want
to caucus and talk about uh reports
though afterwards because this is new to
a lot of our folks okay sure um I don't
need to know right now just whoever gets
it I'll need it by probably next Tuesday
morning if possible we will we will let
you know who's writing the reports I
appreciate it thank you
um without a close executive session and
next up on our calendar this morning is
House Bill 596 and I recognize
representative tenzar for motion yes
thank you chairman I make a motion to
itl house bill 596.
second second
about representative Stone
I think Stone made the motion right we
need to proved second edition
representative was right behind him um
would you like to speak the emotion
representative uh yes thank you again
chairman I I'd like to thank
representative Muse for taking time to
craft this bill however I am voting itl
as this bill is duplicative in nature as
the federal Civil Rights bill covers
this it's just another mirror Bill also
uh police standards and training has
courses on civil rights so they're
teaching their new officers about this
and also departments within New
Hampshire this is integrated into their
shift operating procedures Sops as well
as their Professional Standards of
conduct which is the pscs
thank you represent Stones I'd like to
speak to a second uh Mr cherry wood uh I
take very cautious leads in the language
I was included in this bill and that's
one of the main reasons I also concur
100 with uh representative tenzar that
these issues are already addressed on
many levels to include locals and state
already
thank you for the discussion
somebody must want to talk
representative
sorry thank you
unless for federal agents and so to say
that we don't need to do this because
it's covered by the federal government
um and therefore we can't have mirror
bills seems to me like we're we're
biting both ends of the horse that's not
the right analogy I'm sorry but you'll
have to forgive my favorite brain please
leave the equine population out of it
and um but you know you got my point
that we're we we can't say we're not
enforcing Federal things because that's
up to other people and then we can't
make mirror laws because we don't need
them because there's federal laws either
we're going to make mirror laws
or we're going to set up practices where
we can enforce federal laws but we can't
say we're not doing both that doesn't
seem appropriate
thank you I don't think you need to go
back to yesterday I think we just had
this discussion uh 10 minutes ago on the
previous bill so I think we find
ourselves all on different sides of
particular issues with regard to the
federal government further discussion
thank you so the um
is isn't this help me out because I some
of these are starting to kind of Mumble
into a lot
wasn't this where we were having
difficulty because the driver's license
doesn't say or doesn't have to say
that you know anything about race or
ethnicity I think that was one of the
the kind of conundrums that we had and
the other thing that I have and I'm you
know I was writing real fast but I have
some kind of a note about page two and
on line 20 that it was basically saying
that they wouldn't be able to take the
person's criminal record or history into
account and if I'm remembering that the
testimony that was that was part of what
was said was that that has to be able to
be used
but again full disclosure I wrote really
fast so if anybody can help me I'm kind
of asking general questions to to this
so
thank you and that is exactly the point
of our executive session so that we can
debate this does anyone want to respond
to those representative Murray
I think
um in regards to the first part of what
you said wasn't there a separate bill
that was talking about
um instituting a penalty for police
officers that misrepresented
um race and demographics and I think
that's
um maybe what you're confusing that part
with I don't think it was in regards to
this bill
um
I I believe that the bill that you we
did have something like that but I think
the bill you're talking about is
actually in transportation where it was
saying that the person doesn't have to
say it and I think that was one of the
debates we were having was well if it
was actually required that would that
would solve a whole lot of of the
debates that we continuously have they
go around in circles
so I'm thinking that's part of the
reason why this is not able to be done
not that anybody thinks that this is
okay let's make that very very clear
it is they're you know one hand your
hands tied and the other hand you're
kind of trying to untie it it's it was
it was just a lot of back and forth
confusion but I could be
mistaken
okay
um I think well with regard to this
particular bill
it was my opinion that putting the
police officers in a position where they
had to identify someone's race or
ethnicity or or gender
um was fraught with problems and the
question that was brought up is why can
it not be the person that
self-identifies that way it's not
incumbent upon a police officer to
decide
um all of those things and then make a
report based on that it puts them in a
baptism we even heard testimony about
someone who was um
who was misidentified their race and it
puts the onus in the law enforcement
when the what we're looking for is the
people to identify so that we can track
the law enforcement activity
um and I I just felt that that was uh
inappropriate to put the law enforcement
in that position
someone wants to speak to that
representative Muse
what I what I would like to do is is
remind people of the the primary purpose
of the bill
um the primary purpose of the bill is to
make a clear policy statement that the
practice of racial profiling is
prohibited for law enforcement officers
in New Hampshire
um I do realize that during testimony
um there were some folks who did come
and objected to the second part of the
bill which gets to precisely uh the data
Gathering process used for racial
disparity and sentencing
um I believe and I'm I'm the prime
sponsor of this bill that probably the
most important thing that we can achieve
today is is essentially making a clear
policy statement that no matter
what you feel about uh how
identification data should or should be
gathered
we should make a clear statement that
racial profiling is not acceptable in in
the state
and and I think one one thing that I
would suggest as an alternative is I
would be uh more than willing to uh drop
all of section two
um so we would actually have a clean
bill that really uh gives us an
opportunity to decide whether or not
um
prohibiting ratio profiling is something
that we want to do as a committee
um
so that would that would require uh a
recess of the current hearing a
withdrawal of the current motion uh I
would I could uh request LLS have that
Amendment and hopefully we would have it
by the end of this session
meeting today
yes all right um representative Hill
first you have a comment uh thank you Mr
chair um I sit as well on house
transportation and I think um uh Vice
chairs comments um
I guess is what I'm responding to the
the second the bill that we had and the
house just uh voted in expedient to
legislate on was
um
597. uh this is House Bill 596 we're
talking about here but I think uh from
what I'm gathering and I'll be honest
and saying I haven't read 596 I didn't
realize that was here
but um but representative Muse is is
correct that our problem was
um
the seeming conundrum that we were
asking
for voluntary information
and then
at a time that we were asking that we
make a statement that that ethnicity
is is bad
and then we were going to do something
with that data that was um given up
voluntarily
and trying to um determine how to assess
that information that was given
voluntarily and make major decisions
work
when we were saying that information or
bad data generally makes bad policy so
that was our purpose I'm not sure what
happens when we or if we followed
through with the idea of dropping part
two on this bill um
it would have been a different story I
think in transportation if we had
dropped part two but I'll leave that up
to the chair
thank you
um who made the motion
was it
would you be uh open to withdrawing your
motion
so that representative Muse might
produce an amendment for us to consider
yes I'll withdraw my motion and the
second
I'll withdraw thank you
um having the emotions been withdrawn
I will we recess so that he can contact
that's what I'm going to do I I'm going
to recess this bill and representative
Muse is going to get an amendment
dropping section two
Mr character we have a short break
15-minute bio break
foreign
okay we're still waiting on an amendment
for HB 596 so we're going to take up HP
400 at this point
yep and I will open the public hearing
and Hospital excuse me the executive
session Hospital 400 and recognize
myself for a motion and I move ought to
pass do I hear a second second Mr chair
second and I will speak to my motion
House Bill 400 if you recall was the
bill making it a specific uh and
distinct offense for assault and battery
on a police officer
we heard through testimony that this is
the only state in the entire country
that does not make it a separate offense
to assault the police officer currently
in New Hampshire it's the no different
assaulting your neighbor than it is a
police officer
we ask a lot of our police officers more
and more every day we expect a lot we
hold them to a very high standard and I
think that the least we can do is give
them as much protection as we can and I
believe that assaulting a police officer
is not just an assault on an individual
officer but it's an assault on our
Criminal Justice System they are there
representing the laws enforcing the laws
that we pass and when they assault the
police officer they are assaulting us
and they're assaulting the laws in the
whole system
and that alone should give it
significant
um
difference so that people understand the
seriousness and gravity of it the
increase the difference in the penalties
all I did was take the simple assault
which is currently and I increased all
the penalties one level for a police
officer so I didn't make it crazy it's
just one more level if you do that
and would you like to speak to the
second representative you wrapped it up
nicely thank you would anyone like to
speak on this it's open for discussion
representative pru
well I'm glad to actually see
firefighters and EMS included in this
because unlike law enforcement we don't
have all the tools to defend ourselves
and uh actually I had one of the
firefighters EMTs that worked for me
get assaulted and almost had his nose
broken last week so
um too bad this isn't already in place
thanks well said and I I neglected to
mention that we did extend this to our
EMS workers who also we expect a lot
from especially in the recent years and
to have them come in and risk their
lives
doing the things they do especially
during the covet only to have them
literally slapped in the face for it I
think um Bears an additional penalty um
representative Newell
um I I absolutely agree with uh what you
said and and uh that they are acting in
the public public interest they're in
this position uh because they are acting
on behalf of us and
um I I would
um agree and affirm I would hope that uh
just to add in I would hope that this
would go along with uh body worn cameras
which I know are more and more prevalent
in being used in different
municipalities and sheriffs and things
like that so
um yeah I just think as far as you know
kind of the
demonstrable proof right
representative Cameron thank you Mr
chairman I want to point out one thing I
noticed in the bill that I really like
and it's the law enforcement who has uh
officer has probable cause to believe a
person has violated this paragraph May
immediately arrest such person without a
word
and shall cause such person to be
brought before a judge
for determination of bill so they are
ineligible for a bill commissioner we've
been arguing about bail a lot and if
there's a violence against a police
officer firefighter or EMS they have to
go before a judge for their bail hearing
I think that's a very positive thing
thank you and and the intent of this
wasn't to Tinker with the bail system
because that's a whole other um a whole
other can of worms but in in my opinion
in the opinion of the people I spoke to
if you assault the police officer
um that in my mind makes you definitely
a dangerous person because if you
assault someone whose arm to the teeth
and representing the full force of the
law what else are you are you capable of
doing and I think that that should be up
to a judge to decide
um what what happens to you based on the
individual circumstances of that case
and as we were um as we discovered it's
possible in this state to be arrested in
one town and then later arrested in
another town in the new town not be
aware of your bail status or your um
that you just assaulted a police officer
so until we can fix that uh significant
loophole I think that that is
appropriate for the discussion
representative Muse
so I'm I'm uh I'm sympathetic with the
intent of the bill especially when it
comes to giving some additional
protections to emergency service workers
who I think can use them
um I do have some concerns uh one of my
concerns is this bill
um
does have an impact I think on our our
larger conversation about bail without
uh at least as far as I can determine
without actually amending the bail
statute itself
um my preference would would be to see
this bill uh and this bill retained
along with the other bills that uh that
touch on bail and things that
circumstances that impact the conditions
of bail
I I also have uh some concerns in in
other areas I know that um an area where
that folks thought uh and you know
problematic you know when it comes to
school safety zones is you know how do
how do you how do you know what's a
thousand feet you know do you have some
sort of GPS in your head and so there's
a language in here that basically
requires people where physically
possible
um to remain at least 21 feet away from
the officer if warned so how do you know
exactly how far you are how does the
officer In the Heat of the Moment know
exactly how far away he or she is
um
so there are uh I think that there are
some issues that can be that can be
worked out
um I would prefer to to see them uh
worked out rather than have the bill go
to the floor uh in the last the last
issue is um you know right at the end of
the bill a person is guilty of a class B
felony if he or she knowingly reports to
a law enforcement officer or agency by
word or action false or baseless
information regarding an allegation of
misconduct by a law enforcement officer
and I think I would agree that that
providing that information should be in
offense
but a class B felony to go away for
three and a half years and and I would
also remind folks of the other bill that
we're considering at this time which is
the the
redefining some of the circumstances of
police misconduct
uh so a police under that bill a police
officer who knowingly files a false
report or misidentifies somebody would
be subject to an administrative sanction
not a criminal penalty
so one of the things that we would be
doing especially given the gravity of
the penalty in this bill
um would be having one standard of
Justice
for one type of person who violates the
law and a very very different standard
of justice for somebody else who some
could argue
making a very similar offense
so I just wanted to point those things
out
um and uh and and hopefully kind of in
the spirit of some of the other things
we've been working together on we could
work together on this to make it a
better bill
thank you
um so
with regard to your objections to the
bill were the
the veil portion removed
and a different wording to the 21 feet
perhaps something to the distance
whatever distance the officer requests
something along those lines so it's not
as specific but it lets the officer set
a safety zone
um and the removing the felony turning
it to a a plane misdemeanor would that
suffice to make
that would work much better better for
me there may be other members of the
committee who may have additional input
but
representative
so on the 21 feet that used to be the
old standard for anyone with a knife
couldn't pull out your gun and shoot him
before they stabbed you it's now been
moved to 31 feet so they do know exactly
where 21 feet is
um and this isn't really about bail this
is about assaulting a police officer a
firefighter or EMT public servants that
are there working for you
so they have a little extra protection
and and
yup if you if you're assaulting a police
officer
you're obviously are willing to pretty
much assault anyone so yeah I'm kind of
okay with Nobel at the moment and it has
to go before a judge instead of just the
uh the regular route
so
um I'm good with this bill
thank you uh representative Reed
regarding the decreasing the penalty for
um filing uh you know false information
I think a felony is is quite appropriate
um I think that a strong message needs
to go out that you can't lie
in a report against a first responder or
a police officer because you could walk
away but this is going to follow the
police officer or the first responder
and um no matter how often you know it's
dismissed as you know false allegations
that's that's still there so I think a
felony is is completely appropriate for
misinformation
representative Pratt
anybody that reads the union leader
knows how that turned out recently
police officers assaulted and right
afterwards the person uh stabbed
somebody to death so this right here
would have slowed that one case down and
those kind of things that happening all
the time in New Hampshire unfortunately
now as it has across the country
I'm totally in favor of this build the
way it sits right now thank you
thank you representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I do have to agree with
representative news on a lot of the
points he brought up I honestly just
think this is a lot to tackle in one
bill and they're just small adjustments
like the ones you mentioned earlier that
can make it more amenable
um you know I do agree that it should be
like we should be discouraging people
from assaulting police officers and
other Public Service workers of course I
do think it's hard to make changes
regarding bail eligibility considering
the committee's path on retaining all
other bills to make sure they all
coordinate and work together and make
sense together instead of just pulling
out this one thing and changing it and
in regards to making the false report I
do have to say I think we just need to
really weigh carefully the impact of
felony charge can have on an
individual's life you know during
testimony Chief by fonsi I believe from
Bedford Police you know shared an
example of like say a police officer
pulls over a mom and her kids and she
gets stressed and frustrated and you
know says that he yelled at her and then
reviewing the body cam footage you know
she wasn't he wasn't yelling at her and
now that Mom could go to prison
um with felony charge and I just think
that is such a huge like reaction
um to something that especially if the
officers found not guilty you know what
impacted it
it does the impact really
um
equal to the punishment and when we make
felons of people we're making criminals
of otherwise law abiding citizens I
think we just really need to wait
carefully does the punishment really
match
um the uh negative activity there
thank you representative Manion
thank you Mr chair I do have notes here
and that was a concern of mine uh and I
think what I
got from it was a separation of criminal
allegations versus misconduct certainly
if somebody came to the station and said
that I you know she she swore at me and
or I swore at her and I didn't that
shouldn't be A B felony but if she
accused me of a criminal act where I can
go to jail for and lose my job that's a
little different so perhaps a separation
between
General misconduct versus a criminal
allegation that might
that would satisfy my my position on it
thank you for the discussion
representative
um salik
thank you I just wanted to say that I
agreed with with what representative
Muse was saying I feel like both in the
spirit of where we're looking at the
other bail bills differently that
element of this
poses some challenges for me and and the
level as representative Murray said you
know a distressed mom who makes a
statement out of fear and and
frustration
ultimately potentially losing custody of
her children
um it
it's disproportionate and if we're going
to hold civilians up to these standards
then when we're passing bills about
actual police misconduct there should be
at the least similar standards
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I'd like to point out
to the committee that uh if they're not
aware in New Hampshire RSA 5945 all
individuals have a duty to submit to
arrest in this state
in itself even if you believe that
arrest to be illegal
I'm sure everybody's aware of that or
not a follow-up also on that if you
indulge me is that I would respectfully
disagree with representative Muse I
think uh a lot of people don't
understand the impact of false
allegations and false reports to law
enforcement can be career ending and
life uh changing that's not recoverable
thank you
representative Bolden
thanks um
I feel like the mics are super loud
today
um
I um I wanted to reflect on I guess my
thoughts after hearing uh representative
Murray's um input
another consideration isn't just the
fairness of the punishment versus the
the crime but also the extrapolated
impacts system-wide on the consequences
of that type of punishment because if
you are talking about a single parent or
you know just a parent in general who
has
um dependence then with a felony record
that person is going to end up
on the Welter system and I know that in
other aspects of law that is a common
consideration is you know for example in
the family court system
if um the judge is considering one
decision or another they will take into
consideration whether
you know limiting contact or something
with the children or something will
result in a parent ending up as part of
the welfare system
um and so I think that's a valid
consideration but as far as the
structure of the bill I know that a few
years ago I want to say
maybe 2016 or something there was a bill
in the Senate from
Donna soucy to specifically reclassify
and pull out domestic violence versus
other types of
um you know assault criminal activity
because evidently an issue that she
realized after a terrible incident in
Manchester was that there were people
with criminal records where they if
specifically for domestic violence but
because of how it was classified under
the law it could easily be chalked up to
like a bar fight and that that
distinction was necessary in the law to
enable
particularly people participating in the
family court system or dcif to be
evaluated accurately so that could be
another direction to go with the intent
of this bill
um not necessarily to change penalties
but to create a distinction in the law
as far as
the difference between assault and
assault on a public official
thank you
representative wheeler I just want to
add on my support to a retention motion
I think this is a really good piece of
legislation and I'm conflicted on how
I'll vote for it I think ultimately if
ought to pass motion comes before us I
might vote for it but I do agree with
representative manion's points about
clarifying between General misconduct
and uh uh
forgetting the term criminal criminal
allegations against a police officer I
think that would be a good distinction
to make and uh would satisfy some of
those concerns of other people on the
committee
thank you
um
based on the testimony based on the
discussion I um I'm going to I'm going
to recess this bill and get an amendment
and see if we can't meet halfway on some
of these issues that are reasonable and
do make good points any other discussion
before I do that
representative Peru
so
on that last piece
if somebody makes an accusation against
me
I'm in the back of the ambulance and
somebody says I touched her
inappropriately I'm going to be
suspended more than likely I'll be fired
in a very short time before this even
really gets investigated very well and
it's proven to be a false allegation and
how would I do that there are no cameras
in the back of the ambulance so I may
lose my career
my income
and then I'll be on the welfare system
uh I definitely I definitely agree and I
think that and and that follows you and
I will tell you in New Hampshire
Fire EMS and police is a very small
world
I can be the greatest guy in the world
nobody hears about me I make one mistake
everybody in the system knows about it
and I will never get hired again and I
probably won't even get hired in another
state
yeah and I also um I think that would
probably cause that accusation could
cause an officer to be put on the lawyer
list before he ever has a chance to
defend it uh representative Reed thank
you Mr chairman and another point to
consider is oftentimes municipalities or
towns will settle outside of court on
complaints just to get rid of it so
there's no resolution for the for the
police officers or First Responders and
they're left with this claim this false
claim and um the towns you know or
municipalities just want it gone so
that's another point to consider thank
you thank you very much
um okay
um I'm going to recess the the hearing
excuse me the session on this and um
discussed a little bit and we'll be
taking care of it today
no because it's you know I'm just gonna
get him an amendment
um next we have representative Muse did
your Amendment come through yet
okay we will then
um at this point I will open the
executive session again on House Bill
596.
and recognize representative Muse
everything
now let's see
thank you Mr chair I think we all have
uh we have copies of the amendment now
um what the amendment uh effectively
does is it removes uh sections two and
three of the bill
um uh sections two and three of the bill
uh
effectively uh address the uh the issue
of racial disparities in sentencing in
New Hampshire there were some Provisions
around data Gathering
um it is where the bulk of cost for the
fiscal note uh would would come from uh
and perhaps all the costs of the fiscal
note I need to take to take a coast a
closer look at that but what it leaves
us with is is a clean bill that would
prohibit racial profiling in New
Hampshire
um this is something uh that's bothered
me for a couple of years
um as a member of this committee and I
think all of the members of this
committee when the liac commission was
actually in session we we all followed
it very closely because we know we knew
uh in particular the legislative
recommendations were going to come here
and one of the things I think that
surprised me and surprised some of the
other folks on the committee was that
um the recommendations around racial
profiling really seem to focus solely on
things like identification issues and
driver's licenses and it just seemed
like we never got to to a point where we
remembered that oh yeah maybe in statute
we should prohibit racial profiling
um so uh what I would say is this is
really a policy statement there are no
penalties that are prescribed I think
that if a if an officer is uh uh is uh
uh brought up before police standards
and training around the issue of of of
racial profiling
um police standards and training has a
as a process that they would use to turn
to determine whether or not uh the
officer would uh be suspended keep their
certification lose their certification
but I think one of the things that is is
important here is just sending a strong
message not only to to law enforcement
but also to members of our
our minority communities here in New
Hampshire that
um that racial profiling is not
acceptable uh in this state and
you know in many respects you know New
Hampshire is is firing on on all
cylinders
um I think we could add a cylinder if we
if we pass a bill a bill like this
um that just sends a a very clear
message to everybody about what is
acceptable and what is not acceptable in
law enforcement
thank you
um thank you I do believe though we we
do need emotion on the floor
um I don't recall did you move at this
moment this amendment I I
move uh Amendment uh
2023-0596 uh ought to pass and seconded
by representative Staley is that why
you're okay
and you did speak to your motion um
would you like to speak as well
representative sailing
[Music]
Global Society is learning to recognize
our own
um our own bias whether we're aware of
it or not and my hope is that by putting
language like this into policy that it
will encourage not just training within
the academy
um training academies but also ongoing
training so that we can all work
collaboratively to make the world better
for all of us
thank you for the discussion
so I believe everything following line
well actually everything after the first
page after line 30 on the first page
everything is removed is that correct
representative Muse
um I don't have the numbered version of
it
um but it wouldn't it would uh it
removes everything but the effective
date after
the part that says it's numeral two new
section sentences racial disparity and
sentencing prohibited it removes that
entire section it removes uh section
three involving
um the requirement for the county uh the
counties to provide data in this area
and it would uh it would essentially
make the effective date section too
thank you
further discussion
on the motion about the amendment
okay at that point I would ask the clerk
to call the roll on the vote to pass the
amendment to adopt the amendment
Leicester Rhodes
yes
representative Pratt
representative Hill yes representative
Prue
yes representative janvin
yes representative Manion
representative Reed yes representative
Stone
yes representative tenzai yes
representative Catherine
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative salic yes
representative wheeler yay chairman Roy
terrible GS
amendment is adopted 2-0
the amendment is adopted the bill is
open for further motion I recognize
representative Muse
yes Mr chair I move HB uh 596 FN ought
to pass
with Amendment
second seconded by
representative Murphy
and would you like to speak to your
motion
just very very quickly I know that the
stories like The Tyree nickel story uh
bothered everybody during during the
public hearing one of the things that we
had
um I I think I think one of the one of
the areas where everybody who testified
really did seem to agree was that this
particular move is one that New
Hampshire really needs to make there
were no objections from law enforcement
uh to this part of the bill I think law
enforcement is on board with this too uh
and uh and I hope we can be on board
with it as well as a committee thank you
further discussion representative
wheeler thank you I I do have
reservations about this bill
um I don't think we can legislate away
uh bias or bad behavior and I I do think
that
um
uh the issue of race has been one that's
so pervasive and so deep rooted in the
society that I'm not sure will uh one
bill or any bill will be able to to have
those conversations and get those
feelings out of some people I think it
starts more with conversations and
connections that being said I think I
will Vote for This legislation because I
I do agree with representative Muse that
making this statement that we do not
support racial profiling as a state uh
would be beneficial to starting that
conversation that's needed so I'm gonna
vote
against an ideal motion or four or not
to pass motion if there's one
further discussion
um I I have some reservations
um with regard to this because what what
what happens then
in other words if uh if a law
enforcement officer I mean what is that
what is the standard to which law
enforcement officer will be held for
example by their agency or or for their
certification
um
what is it like in other words how many
how many stops of someone of A different
race does it take before their their
ramifications what what there needs to
be a quantifiable something to say that
this person has violated this and I'm
concerned that it's so broad with no no
mechanism to
to measure it by that it could be used
against Law Enforcement Officers when
there really is no racial bias
but they maybe just
want to use it against them to get rid
of them I don't I don't
I'm concerned about its vagueness with
regard to what the effect would be on a
law enforcement officer any further
discussion on that point representative
Pro
so I'm not a police officer and and
you know do I play one on TV but
um
I'm not really sure how you
enforce this and determine
what was going through that officer's
head when the interaction happened did
it happen because of racial profiling or
was there something else that he saw
that
fell into a category to make a stop or
or whatever
and now everybody says well
was that racial profiling
well no I saw him cross the line so I
stopped him or whatever the case may be
and and just like the chairman said
if they happen to be three people of
color in a row
that did that now is he racial profiling
or was he just in the right spot at the
right time to see this happen
so it could affect the officer
when he's not really doing that
and I agree it's very vague and I get
the statement absolutely
I am 100 against racial profiling or any
of that
but uh how do you enforce it how do you
prove it how do you get in somebody's
mind and say what were you thinking
so to me
too many unanswered questions for me
thank you and and I I were this a um
concurrent resolution to say you know we
the legislature think that racial
profiling is abhorrent and expected not
to be conducted in the state of New
Hampshire I would be voting for it five
times in a row but this seems to create
a situation in my mind where an officer
could be accused of something by
somebody and there's no quantifiable
standard to hold them to and that's
concerning representative Manion
thank you Mr chair uh well nobody agrees
racial profiling is good and uh
I can tell you that in my career
I've been I've stopped someone and
they've said just stop me because of my
race
and you know it could be 10 o'clock at
night we're going I'm going 40 he's
going 70. there's absolutely no way I
would know that but if he makes a
complaint against me
where does this bill come into play does
my department use it does you know
police standings and training use it can
I be sued civilly because now it's a law
and who's going to determine whether or
not that was a racial profiling issue or
was it just because he was speeding so I
just think it's it's a little bit too
broad I have no problem with making a
policy statement or a proclamation uh
certainly we are all in agreement that
racial profiling is not how we conduct
business in this state
um but it leaves it open to police
officers being uh penalized even if it's
not criminally
um as a result there is an attorney
general review on this
are they going to make a determination I
mean it's it's
it makes me nervous thank you
thank you for the discussion
representative Muse
I would say that you know one of the
reasons why we have so much difficulty
with this issue is racial profiling is
so difficult to prove it's one of the
reasons why we have all the ongoing
conversations around how people should
be identified whether we should change
driver's licenses and things like that
um there there are times and I think
there have been times in in the history
of of this state and the history of
others where
um even without identifying somebody
from a driver's license or an
identification method
there is a clear pattern of profiling on
the part of some officers that can be
determined through things like multiple
complaints that are found to be to to
basically be true
I am not saying it is easy and I'm also
not saying that it wouldn't be helpful
to further Define
to you know to to you know to Define
what constitutes it
um I think the definition that we have
uh in this in this particular Bill
encompasses a behavior that we're trying
to discourage here in New Hampshire
um again
this is
the I think the intention of the bill is
to make a policy statement that uh that
the police academy police standards and
training
um can use as part of the communication
that they do with officers as part of
their review of accusations of you know
of misconduct
and I think this is an area where you
have to start somewhere and I think
that's really what this bill is
attempting to try to do it's to give us
a starting point
um uh and uh and there and I would be
the first to agree that we're not done
yet I think Governor sununu when at the
end of the work of the liac commission
basically said the same thing this is
just the start we have we still have a
lot of work to do we have a ways to go
before we're there
and I think that this bill is part of
the Journey of of getting us there and I
would hope that
um we can be we can continue to be on
that journey and to take steps on that
journey in the second year of this
session uh but this bill does give us a
place to start and I would
um I would hope people can support it
thank you
thank you for the discussion
representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman I don't think it's the role of
this committee to make statements I
think we are here to make solid and just
policies having said that there is no
provision in this bill either for
officers or First Responders who work
primarily in cities with higher
densities of immigrant or minority
populations versus somebody who works in
the White Mountains how are you gonna
you know
um protect you know they're going to
have more inter interface how are you
gonna how are you gonna you know tease
that out so that that doesn't come up as
you know having more complaints but it's
just the demographic of where they
Patrol or the area they service
thank you
thank you for the discussion
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I think this bill
clearly has very good intentions but I
don't think it's ready for prime time
yet in my opinion and I'll be supporting
an I.T alumnus
thank you representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I definitely hear the concerns on
both sides of the committee I you know
frankly don't think this bill will like
change things you know it seems like
represented when you said more of a
policy statement
um and you know I struggled to see
departments using this as a way to
punish their officers especially
considering the struggle they are having
in hiring officers right now
um but I also wanted to remind the
committee of last session
um a similar bill was passed that
protected
um bikers from profiling um from law
enforcement and it had similar language
you know it's a another car about we did
to protect a class of people that also
didn't have you know specific
specificities and how it would get
enacted and how officers would be
um held accountable to that um
policy statement so I just wanted to say
that there is precedent for similar
legislation
um even if this one seems incomplete at
this time maybe it is a good first step
in the right direction thank you
thank you
um with regard to the the legislation
you just brought up if I recall that was
um a small paragraph Was it not
thank you
representative amanian
thank you Mr chair not to drag this on
anymore but I'm hearing policy statement
and uh but
representative Muse last testimony he
said this would be used
to identify offices and it would also be
used for police standings and training
for certification purposes those were
his own words so that's my concern thank
you
representative salic
sorry
I um just would would Echo what I was
saying before which is
if we have a statement of policy like
this where if we do have an officer who
unknowingly continues to racially
profile people because I think I I think
that the majority of things that happen
are potentially happening based on
people's unconscious biases and we're
then able to say you know we've received
multiple complaints let's have you do
some training to recognize what's going
on so that we can help your behavior so
that you're doing a better job
protecting the public rather than
focusing on a specific group of people I
don't think that the intent of this bill
is to
um be about punishment it's about
raising awareness it's about raising
standards and it's about increasing
equity and justice
thank you and that is well taken however
it will be used
um in the other way because of the fact
that it it puts a it puts a um an onus
on a police officer not to do a certain
thing but the certain thing isn't
necessarily Quantified and it doesn't
say who will be the judge of that and I
think it it opens them to Serious
um
serious danger with their careers I
would agree with it as I said if it were
just a policy statement and we wanted to
issue a resolution saying that we
um
would not tolerate this in the state
would be different than actually making
a law with an attorney general review
process representative Peru you had a
comment I know it's been a while but uh
point of order can I call call the vote
oh
representative Muse
I wanted to just tell a a quick story
that may help I I have another bill uh
that went before child and family law
passed 16 to nothing we had the
executive session immediately after the
hearing the bill was on Banning the use
of prone restraint on children in New
Hampshire
and one of the things that was pointed
out to me is in the statute if you
actually read the wording of the statute
a reasonable person reading the statute
could could conclude that prone
restraint is actually already banned
problem that we were having is that
there were there were some New Hampshire
Child Care Facilities who were looking
at that and saying I don't see prone
restraint and I think that there's a
safe way to do prone restraint and and
the fact of the matter is is
um
very difficult to do prone restraint
safely when you're a 200 pound adult and
the child weighs 100 pounds
so what what I think we all agreed to
was that a policy clarification where we
specifically called out prone restraint
in the statute and we defined it as we
did here it's actually very helpful from
a policy import enforcement perspective
so it's a it's a related story but I
think what it can do is it can show you
the value of of doing something like
what's in front of us today
thank you
um I think we've had a robust and
healthy debate and I will ask the clerk
to call the role on the motion is ought
to pass as amended
Vice chair wrote no
representative Pratt no representative
Hill no representative proof no
Representative janvin no representative
Manion no representative Reed no
representative Stone absolutely not
Representative tenzar no representative
Kathryn yes representative Muse
representative Bolden yes representative
Bradley yes representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative selig yes representative
wheeler reluctant yay
chairman Roy
Gerald's no
motion fails ten ten
motion is failed and is now open to
further motion
um anyone like to make a motion
representative Stone
I'd like to excuse me thank you Mr chair
I like to make a motion to itl
second
about representative would you like to
speak to your motion representative
thank you Mr chair I would
I think we've had a very good discussion
like I said when my point is I think
this bill has very good intentions I
just think it's not ready for prime time
there's a lot of unanswered questions I
think the reality base is that you have
a department that's responsible for
their officers that's your first level
it goes to pts excuse me uh police
station training Council I can go up to
the federal level and go up to the state
level there's many Avenues I think they
all need to be addressed and I think all
the stakeholders should be invited in to
try to craft a much better Bill if
that's what the committee wants to do or
the sponsor wants to do
would you like to speak to you second
um ditto because I think we spoke enough
about this
further discussion
seeing none of the last card to call the
roll
motion is RTL Vice chair Rhodes
yes representative Pratt
yes representative Hill yes
representative Prue
representative janvan yes representative
minion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tensar yes representative Catherine no
representative muse no representative
Bolden no representative Bradley no
representative Murphy no representative
Newman no click votes no representative
Newell no Representative salik no
representative wheeler no
chairman Roy
the chair boats yes
uh motion fails 10 10. uh it will go to
the floor without recommendation I
representative Stone will you write the
uh the report for the uh I uh OTP and
representative Muse for the I
um for you whatever the other thing
and uh these uh 1010 things are very
confusing
with that I will close the executive
session
on
hp596 and
open the executive session on
House Bill 107 and recognize
representative Manion
and I believe he has an amendment do you
have that yet
uh we do not I would ask that we recess
this executive session until next week
we have a subcommittee meeting on
Tuesday to address the amendment and I
believe we'll be able to come up with
something that's workable to bring to
the group and I trust you we'll take
care of the scheduling for that
um with uh
squawki so
recessed until next Tuesday
Friday Tuesday the subcommittee meeting
we're going to schedule it during
Friday's session okay it's recessed
until next Friday for our purposes and
with that I'll open the executive
session on House Bill 360. no excuse me
yeah 360.
and recognize representative Reed
my motion to itl
second second did by representative who
was it Pratt yes okay
um representative Reed would you like to
speak to your motion
thank you Mr chairman um I am voting to
itl this bill
um for because for many reasons one
being we still don't have any roadside
test uh you know to perform if somebody
gets pulled over for driving Under the
Influence there's no um no test for that
um there's bills marijuana bills in in
other committees
um that um being looked at and I just
feel at this time with our current drug
um problem that introducing another drug
into the mix is just not a good good
idea right now thank you
represent Pratt relates to me to second
sure
I might I'd like to Atlas build uh
National Academy of Medicine says the
regular use of cannabis will increase
the risk of developing schizophrenia and
psychosis
the higher the use the higher the risk
marijuana
routinely contains 20 to 25 percent of
THC of the marijuana that people are
familiar with in the 1970s that's a
hundred times increase of THC over what
it was in the 70s so looking around the
room here the 70s uh
is a lot stronger than what it was in
the 70s
children don't have sense don't have the
sense to make good decisions they get
hooked on drugs just as they get hooked
on painkillers and go into stronger
drugs it will hurt our youth it is
definitely a great gateway drug
there's plenty of things that back that
up
this will degrade our community
there is significant evidence that there
is permanent brain damage from marijuana
use under the age of 25
and it's very similar to lead poisoning
so you can look up the combination
between the two if you like
it will affect our Workforce and
possibly our military
statistics show Highway death rates
related to marijuana have increased in
other states since legalization and
commercialization
35 were in Colorado in 2017 up from 19
so it went from 19 to 35 in Colorado
because of the legalization of marijuana
according to national highway traffic
safety administration 12.6 percent of
weekend nighttime drivers test positive
for THC and between 2013 and 2014
compared to 8.6 in 2007 there is no
acceptable roadside test the levels of
THC in the bloodstream to determine
impairment
but the impairment does exist
and that's it for today
thank you
thank you for that representative Pratt
um
representative Newell
I just wanted to address a couple of
things that were brought up first of all
speaking about roadside testing the
reason why that's so difficult is
because marijuana stays in your system
for up to 30 days and so doing roadside
testing doesn't necessarily describe
whether or not you're impaired so that's
the reason why that doesn't exist and I
I'm not sure how they that would exist
but
um okay but there are experts who can
who try to distinguish I I'm blanking on
what the actual title is but people who
are trained to identify whether someone
is is under the influence impaired in a
way that it would actually
there we go like that I love it
um also
um let me see uh talking about you know
how it was different from the 70s I
think you're right that's that's true
there you know it has been selected to
be more potent the thing is is that when
you legalize something especially for
you know over 21 I think that that's
responsible when you you legalize
something that is when you actually get
to grade what it is what what the
potency is that's how you know what the
potency is because when it's legalized
you can test and analyze and then when
you're selling it
um you know wherever that might be you
are able to say it is this potent it has
this much CBD it has this much THC these
are legalizing it allows for us to be
able to do that in the same way that you
know when we did Prohibition of alcohol
what did we have we had a whole bunch of
alcohol that was out there that was uh
you know on the black market and it was
killing people it was it was killing
people because they didn't actually know
what it was because it wasn't legal
there wasn't a system by which they
could actually assess the potency and
things like that so it does allow for
that and lastly I just want to speak to
you I'm sorry I know I I'm a little
passionate about this one but if I could
just uh speak to the gateway drug thing
um I think that you know as a parent
um I think you know right now it is
scheduled federally alongside heroin
um and I can tell you I my children lost
their father to heroin overdose okay so
I can I can speak to the impact of that
and I absolutely do not want my children
uh doing heroin or anything like that
getting into that absolutely not at the
same time I am very supportive of having
this having cannabis legalized and I
think when we talk about a gateway drug
um I I think in a way it is but we have
made it that and the reason let me
explain why because I don't think that
it is inherently a gateway drug but when
we associate these two things when we
put these things in the same bucket when
we put heroin in the same bucket as
marijuana we are essentially lying to
our children okay and then when um you
know a good amount of them are going to
end up trying it anyway when they
realize that oh well this marijuana
isn't necessarily as bad as my parents
told me because we have lied to them and
put it in the same bucket as very
harmful extremely harmful drugs and then
so when we tell them that this is
alongside those things and they realize
that it's not as bad as we said was as
we the picture we painted they are more
apt to think well maybe heroin isn't as
bad as they said maybe path isn't as bad
as they said that is the way that it is
a gateway drug because we are
categorizing it with drugs that have
absolutely no association with it so I'm
gonna I stepped down from my little soap
box here thanks for the time
other than that do you have any strong
feelings about the bill
representative Bolden
thanks
um I turned my speaker away from
Lauren's speaker I don't know if that's
going to help with the feedback but um
I would just I want to throw out the
idea of retain because I know that the
perspectives on this topic in this
committee are pretty consistently for
legalization
to some degree and
um while this bill might not well isn't
the vehicle it's a shell that can be
used next year if things go south in the
senate or something along those lines I
subbed on Commerce a couple days ago for
the vote on the exact session on the
legalization bill and the bills changed
dramatically
since it was drafted by OLS in the first
place and there's a lot of moving Parts
I think it would be a good opportunity
for this committee to be able to pick up
the subject matter next year if things
go Haywire this year or if there are
some essential components maybe in this
year's bill that are really missed so
just a suggestion to retain
thank you and I'm open to that
suggestion um however keep in mind
retained bills have to be reported out
um by October with a
OTP or itl so it doesn't give us that
much time to sit on it so I'm not did we
not retain one already or did we
we retained it which is marijuana so I
think we've already got one of those in
the uh
in the bucket representative wheeler
thank you Mr chairman um I I'll be
voting against the it on motion on this
bill for a lot of the same reasons that
representative Newell brought up
um I think the real gateway drug is
alcohol that's proven by the numbers I
mean I remember being in high school and
having many more kids in high school
even in Peterborough which is the Old
Hippie town where they used alcohol
significantly more than marijuana it was
it was the that was the party drug and
and I could see that seriously negative
negatively affecting kids minds and
there are studies now coming out that
are saying that no safe amount of
alcohol
no amount of consumption of alcohol is
safe that it can affect your brain that
it leads to dementia and Alzheimer's
even with small amounts of use and
frankly I've seen that in a number of
people
um even kids who are becoming
significantly more forgetful and acting
dangerously acting violently changing
their personality I have not seen that
with anecdotally with the people who I
know smoke marijuana I've I've seen uh
maybe at the most a lack of motivation
which as representative Reed and I
talked about one day is definitely a
concern but not a large enough concern
for me to think that we should be
criminalizing a plant uh which and I I
frankly think that the criminalization
of this
um only causes more problems than than
uh legalizing it would and I don't need
to go on and on about those problems I'm
sure all of us are very aware having
heard these bills so many times but just
the one point I'll make is that there
are people all across this state who in
simply possessing this are now made
criminals because we have uh pushed the
buck off from legalizing the substance
since the 70s so I'll be voting uh to
legalize the substance
thank you
um
representative Hill
thank you Mr chair Mr chair do you
believe that anyone is going to change
their vote from the discussions being
had within our executive session
it's quite possible
representative ceiling
thank you I I just want to add another
component to the discussion
um
and I'll I'll speak anecdotally yeah
anecdotally that's how I use
um which is that there are also a number
of studies and there's evidence and
there are people that I've spoken to
who suffer from Fairly extreme anxiety
ADHD or some combination thereof and the
um
if they add alcohol into their
bloodstream it increases their anxiety
it increases their other symptoms and
leads them to make
generally less responsible choices but
yet alcohol is legal for them to take
when they have chosen to
use marijuana whether by smoking or
using Edibles it's helped them to
compensate and suppress some of the
anxiety symptoms suppress some of the
other symptoms
the other thing is that for a number of
people with ADD ad ADHD and anxiety the
medications for those have a significant
detrimental impact on their appetite
and there are a lot of studies that show
and there's a reason why Girl Scouts
like to set up their cookie stamps next
to dispensaries that people who are
using marijuana
will and it's used in as for medicinal
purposes for this but as an appetite
stimulant and so for people who suffer
from those conditions it can be truly
medically beneficial
um in in terms of the comment before
about it
um being a gateway drug an addictive
it's not the marijuana itself that's
addictive it's often the things that
it's laced with again because it's not
regulated once we legalize it and we can
regulate and ensure that what people are
getting is a pure product
just as we regulate alcohol we can help
protect people from the types of
addictive substances that are often
laced into it
thank you I think at this point
everyone's had a chance on both sides of
the issue to speak I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the rule
foreign
motion is itl
Vice chair Rhodes
yes
representative Pratt yes representative
Hill yes representative Prue yes
representative janvin yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone yes representative
tensar yes representative Cathay
don't do it yeah
representative Muse
representative Bolden no representative
Bradley no representative Murphy
nope
representative Newman
no
the clerk votes know representative
Newell no Representative salic no
representative wheeler nay
chairman Roy
Gerald yes
motion passes eleven nine
um it is itl who will be reporting the
minority representative wheeler would
you like to represent wheeler
hi would you would you like to write the
minorities just all the drug bills Mr
chairman yes I'll have that to you by
the end of today well actually it was
between you actually who was spoke most
most seriously in favor of it I mean if
Jody I believe it was
I am happy to take it representative I
don't know if you've done one yet so
that's even better yeah thank you and
representative Pratt Will you uh be
running the majority or who about the
who made the motion
okay thank you very much
um and that will obviously not be going
on consent
and lastly I have a question for the
committee
um we discussed some changes to House
Bill 400 and I'm going to tell you what
I was about to ask for from OLS however
if you're not going to vote for it
anyway I'm not going to keep everyone
here while I get it so if I make the
changes in change line if everyone could
grab that bill please house bill 400.
if I change
page 2 line 16.
to change it to um
criminal misconduct it would be the
class B felony and then misconduct would
be a misdemeanor
and if I change the 21 feet to a
distance
to a distance specified by the officer
that way no one has to guess how many
feet it's just as far as the officer
says get back and if they don't they be
subject to arrest
and it does I would I would point out
that it does say a reasonable officer
and fear of his safety so someone can't
an officer is not going to be able to
say go back a mile that would not be
reasonable
and I believe that was the only other
Mr chairman would would an arm
I'm just going to throw this out there
like because I see this being a
potential situation as well what's one
one person in my own personal world like
my arm's length is
what I consider to be as far as I want
you to get to me well that's a lot
different for a police officer police
officer he's at least 30 feet for
someone who pulls a knife and runs at
them and they're ready for them to be
able to draw their firearm and stop them
okay that's why thank you yeah
um
wheeler
those changes would change my vote Mr
chairman I would vote I mean the 21 feet
thing I'm pretty sure representative
prues Point made me uh less concerned
about that um but to representative
manion's point if you made those changes
about the misconduct and the the
criminal allegations I would be much
more in favor of voting for this okay
and would do so okay um and I know there
are still concerns about the bail aspect
of it however I cannot bring myself to
change that it's uh um it's we have
several laws on the books that specify
that do make um
bail issues including domestic violence
type issues I while we are going to
address the overall issue of bail and
how we deal with people getting out on
bail and who's going to handle it and
the mechanics of it that does not affect
what we do with certain charges and we
already have some on the books and I
feel like if you are dangerous enough
that you would assault an armed police
officer it needs to be a judge who
decides whether or not you should be
able to be let free so that one I'm not
willing to change so I have one person
willing to support it as is and anyone
else
sure absolutely
I see you down there where we have
attorney head here
just about how having the judge versus
having it go through the what we
currently have as a bail bondsman
process
I'm having trouble wrapping my head
around that and and I just hoping we
could whether it's him or someone else
could just clarify well I think I I can
I can clarify that currently if you were
arrested and you assaulted a police
officer it's a simple assault charge
um they would call the bail clerk if it
was after hours they would come in and
uh not the bill collect the bill
commissioner and they would uh
set the bill at whatever they've deemed
appropriate at the time but my concern
was is that we currently have a
communication problem where someone
could have already been arrested and
that person would not know it so you
could have multiple people you could
have someone released on multiple
charges out of different police stations
and one of those being for assaulting a
police officer and the next place
wouldn't even know that you're out on
bail so right now we have some issues we
have to handle as far as the whole
situation goes the bail system which is
why we retained the other bill
go ahead representative Newell thank you
Mr chair
um I think what's really kind of keeping
me on it because I I do think that it's
a good intent and it's uh it's it's good
um at the end of the day I'm I'm
concerned about you know
we we entrust what we talked about
earlier was um that they are
representing the public and representing
the public and acting on behalf of the
the public and really I mean you know
the the cliche way you know having a
monopoly on violence right but at the
end of the day if we entrust uh police
officers with that
um and especially when it comes to uh
firefighters EMS you know other people
that we're including like I said in the
first place um I talked about body worn
cameras those are not consistent across
the board and I think that you know um
I just think that with that uh that
power and responsibility
um comes
um accountability is necessary and a
high burden of proof at that point so
I'm I am concerned about kind of um
unintended consequences from it
potentially and um I mean absolutely no
offense to anyone when I say that I
think that you know the burden of proof
on all in all ways should be but if
we're
um attaching these kind of heightened
um penalties for it I think you know we
really need to have heightened
accountability to accountability to go
along with that
thank you and um currently the the state
at the direction of the governor has
formed a commission that is going to
adopt a set of very rigorous standards
um for accreditation across the state
and um they're in the process of
compiling that right now and part of
that a lot of these issues are going to
be in order for a department to consider
itself accredited they're going to have
to meet these standards and they're set
most of them or many of them are
mandated by the federal doj so it's it's
going to be quite rigorous
representative Newman
um I'm just concerned about this whole
conversation I didn't hear exactly what
you were trying to do uh I understand
that we discussed things but I I am just
the part I'm concerned about is we're
asking people kind of polling people for
whether they would vote for the bill not
having seen the written amendment I just
think that's important thank you yeah um
but these this is obviously a
non-binding poll I'm trying to see
whether it's worth the committee's time
for me to obtain the actual
Amendment and represent Muse
foreign
in the spirit of the way we've been kind
of dealing with the bail issue all along
um something I might suggest if we're
going to amend the bill uh would be to
put that section out but to park it Mr
chair for our our conversation so I
think that there I think it's actually
possible for us to pass a bill that's
helpful that does a lot of the things
that people have said they want to do
um but but for me the inclusion of the
bill provision would be a would be a
deal breaker because I think it goes
against
um what we've been talking about for all
of our other conversations regarding
regarding bails so I hate to be the
person who gums up the works
um but I I do have a strong preference
for for dealing with all of the bail
issues down the road and and not picking
because I mean if we wanted to I mean
I could there were things that I can
pick apart especially about another bill
that's going to come in front of us 653
um and you know and unfortunately I
think if we if we if we do it once
um you know we're going to have a harder
time down the road so my suggestion
would be let's not let's not forget
about this let's make it part of the con
the conversation but in the spirit of
getting through legislation that would
be helpful
um it would be I would
ask you to consider removing it
thank you and I I am taking what you
just said into consideration
representative Pratt
uh we talked about reducing the criminal
aspect of this could you uh speak a
little bit more on that sure so what it
would do is if you make a false
allegation against a police officer that
the police officer committed a crime
that would be
um a felony a class B felony if it's
simply that they did misconduct I.E the
circumstance where the representative
said the mother said uh you know you're
yelling at the most that could be is a
misdemeanor
um and if it was proved that it was
intentional and it was blatantly false
so that's a pretty high standard but it
still has teeth to it so that stays the
same yeah oh okay
okay
um with that I'm gonna and I know
everybody wants to go home but we're
doing pretty good here so I'm going to
call her a recess until
um let's take 45 minutes
um 12 15. I'll see if I can get this
amendment and we'll get this done and
we'll get out of here for the weekend
representative Bolden
thank you
um I just want to say I agree with
representative Muse it'd be cool to just
pull it out save it for later the Bell
part but I mostly want to say I think
you're doing a really great job as chair
I think you're really fair and polite
and I appreciate it I think everybody
agrees I'm really sorry that we're being
mean to your bill
what did you do wrong Amanda that's okay
um I think that you could make it up by
taking me lunch
foreign
questions
the whole thing was established and run
by our New Hampshire
yeah just Google like New Hampshire
lawmaker Scandal there's like so much do
you know about the rescue Yelp sea Kyle
yeah at the speaker and then the speaker
asked him to apologize so he apologized
he was very unhappy with the speaker and
was trying to make a commentary about
his practices
that we were voting in the bill to make
the Redstone property
um
we were debating the bill it wouldn't
have been not introduced but it was it
was put in at the behest of a bunch of
fourth graders who were in The Gallery
that day that the bill was being debated
to a Catholic floor and this Republican
took a mic apart about how the Red Tail
Power to make it better and mascot for
Planned Parenthood because of how the
river
yeah and they're all sitting and only
Sports here soon so that means like
international news wow
party
yeah
my friends
0602 is the amendment number that is the
one that was just corrected oh six
okay at this point I'm reopening
executive session on House Bill 400 and
I am going to move Amendment
20230602 do I have a second second Mr
chair
thank you um speaking to the amendment I
listened to everyone and I've made
numerous changes to it
um I've changed the from the felony to
the misdemeanor a Class A misdemeanor if
they make a false report about a law
enforcement officer involving a criminal
offense and it's an unclassified
misdemeanor if they make a false report
by about a police officer or any EMS
file I added that to that is a active
misconduct against their rules of
regulations or the um
training Council and then
I also took out the part about bail
so the bail issue will be dealt with as
part of the overall bail when we get to
that and I believe that was everyone's
concerns
I could not possibly do any more
yeah I think actually is a as a matter
of process I have to withdraw my OTP
motion who seconded it I'll withdraw my
second mystery okay so then now the
motion on the floor is the amendment and
does anyone want to discuss that before
we vote on that
I believe so yes
yes
or did they
no they they didn't they just changed it
yeah they just shows the it reflects the
changes from the original bill
yeah we have to remember the amendment
then we vote on the bill as amended okay
but this amendment does reflect all the
changes that we've discussed so having
said that I would ask the clerk to
please call the role in the amendment to
adopt the amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt
yes
representative pru
representative Jan Wren yes
representative mannion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative Guthrie yeah
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative selig yes
representative wheeler
yes
chairman Roy
CE yes
amendment is adopted 19-0 okay at this
point I would move ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 400 do I have a
second second seconded by representative
prove
um I believe enough discussion unless
someone else wants to discuss it
no okay
um clerk please call the roll
Vice chairwelt yes
representative Pratt
yes
representative proof
I'll take that as a yes for
representative okay
um representative chandrin
representative Manion yeah yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tensar yes
representative gathright
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative selig
representative wheeler yay
chairman
Chevrolets yes
OTP passes motion passes 19-0
very good thank you that was a great
piece of bipartisan work we did here
today I think and uh thank you very much
and I closed the executive hearing on
that bill and I opened executive a
reopening executive hearing on House
Bill 351 and I understand representative
Muse has a an amendment
and or that we probably already have
would you please like to move your
amendment I have an amendment
um I move
Amendment 2023
-0592h
to HB 351 FN Auto pass
do I have a second
representative saley
would you like to speak to your motion
yes with this what this bill does is it
increa is it uh
uh it strengthens uh New Hampshire's
Firearms negligence law uh regarding
children
um uh the amendment the amendment also
eliminates the first part of the bill
that that folks had problems with that
would have required uh all uh transfers
and sales of guns in New Hampshire
including Private Sales
to be accompanied by a locking safety
device there was testimony of the
hearing that
um that the expense of that may place an
undue burden on some on some gun owners
there was also testimony
that some devices are more effective
than others
and one of the things I think that we
all did agree on when we took a really
good look at our Firearms negligence law
is is that
um it's extremely weak the way that it
stands it can use some beefing up and uh
uh and and I think the other thing that
we agree on is that any
any incident involving an unsecured
firearm in a child
um is uh
an incredibly unnecessary tragedy uh and
and I think our goal as a criminal
justice and Public Safety Committee is
you know to do the best we can to
minimize those incidents and by
um not only increasing increasing the
penalty uh but also hopefully by getting
uh some publicity for the fact that
we're we're actually making the change
and and gee whiz if we do this we're
actually enacting
um a uh a firearm safety measure that
that finally hopefully everyone can
agree on
um we can agree that we we want to keep
kids as safe as we can so
um in that spirit I offer this amendment
and I hope that you vote for it thank
you
representative selig would you like to
speak to you second
yes thank you I I'm very strongly in
support of this amendment and this bill
um we had a situation in the community
where I live where a child was having a
party and brought out a loaded weapon
to display to his friends one of whom
went to get the parents and say they
were frightened and the parents response
was to laugh
and then take the gun and put it away
the child said I want to call my parents
and go home and the parents said no you
can't do that and made the child stay
despite the child's discomfort
to me there should be a criminal penalty
for for doing that you know it's it's
wrong it's unsafe we're lucky that no
one was inadvertently shot during that
interaction but also in my community
seven years ago we lost a child to a
fifth grader to suicide by
self-inflicted gunshot wound from an
unsecured firearm in the family and so I
just think whatever we can do to help
save our kids and protect our kids is
crucial
further discussion
representative wheeler
one of my closest friends lost their uh
partner to a similar situation
uh representative selig
um you know the firearm was stored
poorly he was drunk and on some pills
and had depressive thoughts and
had access to a weapon that was Loosely
stored and shot himself and it was one
of the hardest things that our entire
friend group ever went through and we
were still reeling to it years later and
I really appreciate representative
Muse's Amendment on this it has changed
my vote on this bill and I appreciate
the intent of the bill and us doing
whatever we can to make sure that what
had happened to my friend group and
happens to many friend groups as
representative
Illustrated uh doesn't happen again and
I I think doing whatever we can on that
end is is the right move forward and uh
I'll be voting for this legislation for
Alejandro
thank you
um further discussion on the amendment
seeing none please uh clerk called the
roll on the amendment this is um
this is the adoption of the amendment
vote
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt
no
representative Prue yes
representative janvin
representative Manion yes
uh representative Reed yeah
representative Stone no
representative tanzar yes
representative gathright
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes
cloak for uh clerk votes yes uh
representative Newell yes representative
selig yes
representative wheeler
yay chairman
cheer votes yes
motion passes
17-2
representative Muse would you like to
make a motion
thank you Mr chair I move uh HB 351 FN
as amended ought to pass with Amendment
second
who seconded it representative Murphy
seconded it
um would you like to speak to your
motion representative Muse
um
I just want to uh want to thank uh thank
the chair uh for once again uh being
flexible for allowing us to do things
like this
um uh it feels good to get good things
done
um and that's all I'll say thank you
thank you much
anyone else representative Murphy would
you like to speak
do a second
no I think representative you said it
all thank you thank you
I don't know that's a good question
um
it's open for discussion at this point I
have a question representative Muse on
the on the bill when we talk about
Firearms exhibited or displayed to other
minor children who are members of the
household with with that would that not
qualify for example if I have a rifle uh
above my mantle or if I have it in a
glass gun cabinet where it's displayed
uh with lights on it so you can see it
with that with that
it's displayed in the sense that we use
it and our other in you know in other
parts of our law uh where we're talking
about uh displaying the weapon openly
but the the assumption would be that the
the child would be handling the weapon
at that point okay so any person who
stores or leaves on premises under
control
an unloaded firearm with unsecured
compatibles in such a manner that is
available to a child with the
supervision or without the supervision
or permission of child's parent Guardian
this gets me if the child gains access
farm and the firearm is displayed
exhibited so the precursor that
necessary to that would be the child
um gains access to the firearm okay
so that would be covered
and what what this specifically does
address uh would be and and bring within
the scope of the the concept of
negligence is currently in order to be
charged with a violation uh somebody who
leaves an unsecured firearm out uh the
child would actually have to pick up the
firearm use it in a reckless or
threatening manner use it in the
commission of a crime
um or you know negligently and
recklessly display it so
um what it what it doesn't cover are
issues like the incident uh that
happened a few weeks ago with a
six-year-old brought the firearm to
school
um shot his teacher
um it it would cover incidents where
children you know and and I do
understand that we do have an existing
law against fire against children
bringing Firearms into a school but uh I
think the idea is that um in kids are
kids and a lot of times when an
unsecured firearm kind of comes into
their hands they go they look at it
almost as a toy and something it's it's
exciting it's different it's something
to show their friends
um uh it's something their parents may
be proud of and
you know it's hard to go back to sort of
thinking like a child but the but the
issue is is when you when you when a
child takes an unsecured firearm out of
the home brings it into somebody else's
home brings it into a place where other
people are present
um not only do you have a you know the
the danger of
um the child accidentally firing the
weapon you also have you know the the
danger sometimes of an accidental
discharge if they just drop the weapon
so from a from a safety perspective
um I from a public safety perspective I
think that what this would do is is
actually bring within the scope of the
law
um uh a lot of the incidents I think
we've been hearing about and and that
we've been concerned about
um and uh and and it would make our our
current law which you know and I think
if you if you if you look at the RSA the
way it currently reads it's a little
ridiculous that ours that are standard
for negligence is is so high that the
child actually needs to fire the gun
shoot somebody
um or committed commit a crime with it
in order for somebody to be to be
charged with um with a violation
um and um so I think the bill uh sends a
it just it reinf what I would I would
put this into the category of something
that reinforces our current policy
um this this is something
we don't want any gun owner to leave an
unsecured gun in anywhere where a child
can get it and and what this does is it
basically reinforces and confirms our
existing policy and uh uh and sends a
strong message that um yes under the
Constitution you have the right to own a
firearm but you also have the
responsibility to keep it out of the
hands of a minor child thank you that's
what we're trying to do here thank you
any further discussion anyone else have
anything
seeing none um I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll on the motion is on the
pass is amended
Vice chair Rhodes
no
representative Pratt no
representative Prue no
representative Jan van no
representative Manion
representative Reed
no representative Stone no
Representative tanzar no
representative Catherine
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
let me get my mind right
s thank you
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative salic yes
representative wheeler
yay
chairman Roy
snow
motion passes 10 9.
motion passes 10-9
um the bill is
ought to pass
um it will not be on consent
um
representative Musa you'll obviously be
writing the majority report anyone want
to volunteer to write The Minority
Report
representative Stone thank you for
stepping up to the plate again
you have a future in writing should you
decide legislation is not for you
um having said that I I thank you all
for another hard week
um we're almost at the end of the road
as far as our bills go we will be done I
think a week early
um so I'm hoping we're all going to get
a week off before we get the stuff from
the Senate and
um again thank you for all of your work
in the by Patterson Manor we got some
good legislation done and I will see you
all next week thank you Mr chair